hey chess friends national master james
canty the third here with chess.com and
today we have game
of the day with the white pieces we have
leela just zero
and with the black pieces we have stock
fish let's get right into it let's see
what we got we have
d4 and d5 now we may see a queen's
gambit or
queensland declined or maybe uh ready
something like that we'll see what we
have here
london system oh c4 queen's gambit and
we have a queen's gambit
accepted oh yeah it's going to get very
aggressive here this is a very
aggressive line against the queen's
gambit
so if it's something you want to play of
course you do need to do your research
but it is an aggressive way to play
against the queen's gambit
now we accept it and here white has
gamut it upon and usually gambit is for
rapid development or something greater
so after d takes c4 knight f3 saying hey
we're going to get this pawn anyway it's
doubled
we don't care about it right now we can
also have two center pawns if we like
later on
now a6 and e3 being a standard move here
so we can take back on c4
a6 is about b5 so we can defend our
extra pawn
that we got for free so after b5 there's
a4 you want to attack this pawn chain as
quickly and as fast as possible
100 a4 attacking the pawn chain saying a
if you do not do anything about this
this undefended rook cannot help
and we're going to take on b5 which
means c4 is going to hang
and you can't take back due to rook
takes a8 so we have bishop b7 from
stockfish here
very nice move just defending the rook
that's on a8 so if a takes b5 we can
take back and the rook is defended
now bishop b7 and b3 one thing you want
to do when you see upon chain attack
upon chain
not all the time but many times more
often than not
if you see upon chain you attack the
pawn chain especially if it's not yours
so of course we're going to break this
up as much as possible stockfish
realizes that this is a lost cause and
instead of playing b4
we play e6 here actually just to make
sure that our bishop gets out
this pawn is gone anyway c4 we're going
to give it back when we want to
and after e6 b takes c4 b takes c4 and
now
bishop takes c4 very strong move getting
the bishop out in one move not two
sometimes you'll see bishop b2
then captures and then takes but you
have to move that two times to do that
we were able to move the bishop out in
one move bishop takes c4
and again when you see upon chain attack
upon jane
c5 and we lie very strong stuff here
instead of castling
we did c5 now after castles there's
knight f6 and then after knight f6
there's knight b
to d2 which is a very strong move as
well knight b to d2 is extremely strong
it's just getting the pieces out and
we're going to say bishop to b2 to put
the pressure on the long diagonal
use the file with a smile as well but
after knight b to d2 their c takes d4
opening the lineup for our bishop knight
takes d4 because we don't want an
isolated pawn
if we take this way the pawn is isolated
it's a huge target and black doesn't
have any weaknesses
so c takes d4 wouldn't be or he takes d4
wouldn't be good from white
knight takes d4 from lula chess and
knight to c6
instead of going something like bishop
e7 and castling very interesting knight
to c6 getting rid of this knight already
before it becomes very strong
okay knight c6 captures captures and
queen to c2
putting pressure on c6 so bishop to e6
is actually in the air now
and bishop d6 says do it anyway i don't
care but look at how these bishops are
so sharp on this side of the board
they're bearing down on white's king's
side
wow this is pretty strong let's see if
we can develop an attack from it
bishop to d3 attacking the c6 pawn not
going for bishop e6 because there's
tactics even queen c7 could help
just like what was played in the game
queen to c7 defending the bishop
the best defense is offense so instead
of just defending the bishop and
we're going to defend it but also attack
h2 at the same
time queen c7 and then bishop to b2 now
we're bearing down on this very long
diagonal here
and you know it's very strange right
because you have moves like f4
g3 h3 right as a human
as a human you would probably do what
defend
the h2 pawn makes total sense here but
actually
which these are moves here but instead
of
passive defense you want to go for more
of an aggressive offense
even though you are you're losing a pawn
on h2
but bishop to b2 is actually saying hey
instead i'mma let you have the pawn
you can have it which stockfish says oh
yeah i'm gonna take those
bishop takes h2 that's check king h1 and
then we're going to bring that right
back bishop to d6 because we want we
don't want to be trapped with g3
but we can't play it anyway but we just
don't want the bishop to be trapped on
h2
so now we have this long diagonal that
maybe we can use later but after bishop
to d6 there's
now f to c1 this move here does put
pressure on the c6 bishop
saying that hey yeah you got your pawn
but i'm going to put so much pressure on
you
tied down of course with the a pawn the
a6 pawn being weak as well there's a lot
of issues here
we're going to try to do as much as we
can and pressure you at the cost of the
pawn i gave you
rook after c1 rook to c8 defending the
bishop here
bishop takes a6 is in the air but if you
play bishop takes a6 there's actually a
nasty move
of bishop takes g2 ouch yikes
tactics win games queen takes c2 you're
in trouble
on the double that's not fun there right
so let's get out of the way so after
rook f to c1 we have rook to c8
queen to d1 getting out of the way and
then we have a queen to b7 we don't want
to stay
into a pin like this or a self-inflicted
pin or an x-ray where the queen sits
right there
so queen of b7 a double attack here on
the bishop and the g2 pawn
so what happened to the doors of your
house look at this bishop takes g2
and it came to g1 and rook takes but if
you look at this after rick takes queens
to take c1
and you look at this position imagine
you having doors in your house of course
you should
most houses have doors in them now the
doors are all open
every single one of them and the windows
and anything or anyone
can come inside and if you look at
white's position here this is exactly
what that looks like right now this is
very tough as white has no
shelter around the king besides this
pawn but that's not really much maybe
one of the doors are closed
but the rest of it is is wide open here
with the bishops
looking like monsters on this side of
the board
well after queen takes c1 it's black to
move here guys what do you do
you castle you're also you know you got
to be aware of this
right now so do you move the queen maybe
queen a8 strange move but you also got
to watch out for the c8 square
you know there's a check back here
there's a lot going on
now remember this i'm going to give you
a quick tip here the best defense is
offense
black to move what would you play
here it is guys well uh instead of
something crazy
maybe like queen a8 or like you know
defensive you know
moving the queen c6 maybe bishop c6 is
no good
you got to make a queen move because the
bishop here but instead
of moving the queen at all well let's
just go knight g4
for the score wow that's a big boy move
oh my goodness what are you doing well
let's just see if bishop takes g7 well
gg start a new game
that's not a move bishop h2 is mate and
we great look at that that's beautiful
queen's defending the bishop
even though we're attacked yeah it's
mate nothing you can do about it
so you have to defend the mate very
strong so after knight g4
let's go back to knight g4 there's
bishop e5 saying okay i'm still going to
attack your queen
but i'm doing in this manner and now of
course if bishop takes e5
thinking you're going to mate well you
are very very wrong and it's very sad
because now king takes g2 is in the air
because the queen's gone ouch that hurts
this is a family channel
so queen to d5 queen d5 is a very good
move here queen c8 is extremely scary
but we are actually able to get out of
it after queen of d5 there's bishop
takes d6
and then king queen takes d6 and king
takes g2 so if we look at the material
count white's down a piece but white has
no king shelter
so now we this is an all out attack here
queen h2 check
king f3 we take on f2 and what do you do
and king takes g4
because if king to e4 being one of the
only moves of the two
you play queen takes the e3 and that's
me start a new one ouch
okay well king takes g4 and the king is
in the middle
of the street imagine crossing the
street without looking both ways
this is exactly what's going on with
this king right here on g4
unbelievable now surprisingly here i'm
gonna let you find this move here
black to move what are you gonna do f5
h5
queen g2 queen takes e3 what are you
gonna play
here it is guys now this is a miraculous
move in fact
the moves like f5 and h5 actually lose
in insane nothing that we would ever see
these moves actually don't even work
the way that you think they would the
reason being is because our king
at the end of it right now is still very
unsafe so in fact the move is actually
castles here
now we can go for everything else now
and actually check this out
we're down two pieces now says stock
fish
two pieces two times two pieces
right castles knight of three okay and
the king is in the middle of the street
h5 and we live so if you take we're
going to take on f3 and this should be
enough to win the game
king f4 though we're going to stay
around the knight and an e5 check
trying to divert the king away from the
knight king e4 and then instead of
playing f5 and opening up more lines
instead engine move queen to g3 queen to
g3 two engines playing here you're going
to see engine moves bishop c4
of course uh pinning the pawn because f5
is coming
queen g4 check of course the king d3
you can just do this and then takes
this is winning for black you do have a
queen um coming and it's also easier to
play as black here
check like you have the extra bishop but
this is not really helping we actually
have pawns
think about this we're up pawns so yeah
we're down a piece
but we have the pawns to compensate us
and the king is in the middle
of civilization nowhere away or nowhere
around anything that we want
as white so queen check king takes c5
rook e8 and we great
hitting the king on e5 like the king
goes from e1
to castling to e5 like you can't even
draw an arrow like that
it's just so amazing that this king's in
the center of the board two pieces down
for black and we're decisive here now
this move right here is extremely hard
to find here guys
you may think it may be rook d8 check
and maybe queen g6 check
what do you think the move is maybe
queen takes f3 black to move once again
your move what are you gonna do
and here we go guys after king takes
after king to d6
queen f5 cutting the king off
from freedom from running back into the
civilization
this way we're actually going to cut him
out of of anything
cut him off from the file so queen of
five is very strong bishop to e2 and
then there's queen e6 check
king c5 and rook c8 we just take the
queen right
king d4 and then we queen d6 ah when you
find a good move look for a better one
gotcha there
most of you would have took in the queen
absolutely of course why not but if you
take the queen here
you know you you could still win this
but it is difficult when you do have
it's more difficulty involved because
there's three pieces which is usually
equal to a queen
which is or even more honestly but you
actually don't
take the queen you actually always look
for the better move if it's possible
rook c8 king e5
or king d4 and then queen to d6 check so
the king can't go
obviously this way so we have to go to
the center of the board and instead of
taking the queen ah rookie a check oh my
goodness
and now if you go king f3 not for me
queen of six
that's mate and we grade the game is
over look at that but
that didn't happen instead the only move
is knight to e5
now getting back one of our pieces says
stockfish rook takes c5
king at three and then rook f5 we're
going to bring the king right back to us
king back on g2 this is insane king went
to e1
to d4 all the way back to g2 and let's
see if we got any more king moves we can
make rook to g5
king f3 okay queen f6 check king to e4
i mean this is this is insane a dancing
king right
man look at those feet move king d3 rick
d5 check
king c3 and you know what we'll take the
queen now
says stockfish because we're up now now
we don't have to worry about that extra
piece you had
you only have two which is easier to do
especially when you have uh
these extra pawns like black does rook
takes c1 and the rest is honestly
technique let's see it h4 bishop c4
queen to d6 check king e2 lots of moves
left so we're gonna fly through this
queen h2 check king d3 queen of g2
threatening the queen
very easy rook to c2 and we step out of
the way with a check so we can push the
pawn
king to c3 we uncheck him first and then
we push the pawn because this is our
extra asset here to get rid of one of
these pieces and then we're actually
going to uh
queen anyway with the other pawn now
after h3 there's bishop d5 or other
pawns
g5 rook c4 queen b6 check lots of moves
here guys lots of moves because there's
just technique
there's still a lot to do but more
easier to play
for black than it is white because white
has no pawns no shelter
that happened even after bishop takes h2
and bishop takes g2
and what do you do and this game is
really bad for white here so after rick
the c3 does uh queen e2
king b3 queen d1 check right we're just
pushing this pawn and
thank you for the other piece now you're
only down those two pieces you had
they're gone now or even at least on
pieces we are
not on the board though we are
definitely winning in all aspects here
beautiful move queen h4
saying uh we're just we're gonna do it
this way it's so funny you could have
done it so many ways
but almost like in a troll moment from
stockfish here just saying all right
take the queen
and of course he doesn't take it playing
g4 now and queen to g5 or uh
queen g5 g3 and we're gonna push this
pawn right through
with with ease with ease we take the
rook now let's let's watch the last few
moves here king b3 queen c6 a5
g2 king b2 and queen c4 cutting off the
board
you can easily just use the king as well
or just queen and mate in a few
king b1 g1 check king b2 and queen b
aquina g to c1 checkmate and we great
that game is over that was a beautiful
sacrifice there a double piece sacrifice
in a way there which is very nice from
stockfish that's an amazing game
and hopefully you learned something
definitely play this video back to see
it
over and over again thank you so much
for watching i hope you enjoyed today's
game of the day i'm national master
james canty iii here with chess.com
and i'll see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you